З кінця березня по кінець червня - сезон спаржі, улюбленого німецького весняного делікатесу.
Утім, без робочих рук зі Східної Європи місцевим фермерам ніяк не обійтися.
Які основні правила для сезонних працівників цього року
і чи можуть у період пандемії приїхати на роботу в Німеччину охочі з України?
Фермери у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії лише готуються до початку сезону.
Через холоди спаржа затримується у землі.
Збирати врожай шляхетних овочів почнуть за два тижні.
Утім, після важкого минулого року з гострим дефіцитом сезонних працівників
через пандемію нині приїзду заробітчан ніщо не заважає:
Ні, немає жодних складнощів. Єдина додаткова умова -
працівники повинні мати з собою негативний тест на коронавірус.
А все решта -  стандартні процедури. Ми надсилаємо контракт.
Його там перевіряють. І тоді вони можуть приїздити.
В даний момент жодних проблем. Я, звичайно, не можу передбачити,
як буде з короною. Адже завтра все може помінятися.
Ферма "Штайґер" - невелике родинне підприємство. Їй вистачає шести сезонних працівників.
Цього року вони приїдуть з Румунії. Крім того, двоє помічників працюють на постійній основі.
Минулого року обидва моїх помічники мусили поїхати на батьківщину.
І тоді в нас не було жодних. Тож ми мусили набрати німецьких сезонних працівників.
Але зрештою все вдалося. Яких тільки професій не було -
і зірковий кухар, і столяр, і студенти, і навіть вчителі.
Помічники з Польщі, Румунії та Болгарії нині можуть без проблем в'їхати в країну,
потрібна лише реєстрація, оренда житла та тест на корону.
Перші 10 днів після приїзду - так званий робочий карантин,
коли не дозволяється виходити за межі ферми. Але якщо працівники
прибули із зон із мутаціями вірусу, то діє 14-денний карантин без права на роботу.
На фермі "Штайґер" вирощують широкий асортимент овочів та фруктів, розводять курей.
Вимоги до санітарії в умовах пандемії прості -
працівники зобов'язані тримати дистанцію одне від одного.
Якщо група працівників проживає в одній кімнаті,
то і працювати на полі, і харчуватися вони мусять лише цією командою,
без контакту з іншими бригадами.
На полі маски носити не потрібно. Там є достатня відстань.
В нас є подружжя працівників. Вони не мусять тримати відстань,
це було б ідіотизмом. Навіщо їм тримати відстань?
Вони, звичайно, не наближаються до інших.
Аби не бути контактними особами. Тому що інші - в магазині.
А ці двоє - на виробництві. Тож безконтактність можлива.
Можлива не означає, звісно, що абсолютно гарантована.
Через пандемію українців на німецьких полях очікується
значно менше, ніж у минулі роки. Здебільшого до робіт
будуть залучені громадяни Румунії. І все ж, українці теж
можуть приїздити на сезонні роботи до Німеччини, попри суворі в'їзні обмеження.
Однак, увага, наразі єдина категорія, якій це дозволено -
це студенти та школярі, застерігають в міністерстві сільського господарства Німеччини.
Право на в'їзд регламентується як для проходження літньої практики.
Причому байдуже, німецький це чи український навчальний заклад.
Максимальна тривалість роботи - 90 днів протягом року.
Принциповий момент - звертатись охочим потрібно
до українського представництва Федерального відомства праці Німеччини
і у жодному разі не до приватних фірм.
Приїзд на роботу нестудентів регулюється окремими
українсько-німецькими домовленостями, повідомили
на запит DW в аграрному міністерстві ФРН:
Торік, аби врятувати врожай, Німеччина дозволила у квітні і травні
приїхати 80 тисячам сезонних працівників зі Східної Європи.
Авіакомпанія Eurowings навіть організувала для їхньої доставки чартерні рейси.
За оцінками, потреба ферм Німеччини
в іноземних працівниках становить понад 300 тисяч осіб.
Спаржа - овоч доволі дорогий. Від 12 до 20 євро коштує в середньому один кілограм.
За цим стоїть важка робота. Щоправда, непогано оплачувана.
Спаржа відкриває сезон. Потім також  збиратимуть полуниці,
чорниці, ревінь, цибулю, картоплю, цукрові буряки, пшеницю й кукурудзу.
Фірма-посередник, яка везе людей до Німеччини, часто не має жодного уявлення
про реальні умови праці, хоч і роздає щедрі обіцянки.
В оголошенні рекрутерів може бути вказана погодинна оплата.
Насправді ж господар платитиме за кількість кілограмів зібраних овочів.
Зарплати для східноєвропейців дуже різняться, залежно від підприємства.
Додаткові санітарні заходи коштували великим фермам десятки тисяч євро.
Установка додаткових контейнерів для більш просторого розміщення людей,
послуги з прибирання й дезінфекції, тестування робітників,
оплата шляху додому після оголошення локдауну.
Держава відшкодувала частину витрат, але спочатку гроші потрібно
було знайти самим підприємствам.
Тож багато з них усе ще переживають непевні й нелегкі часи.
Неподалік від Бонна розташоване знамените господарство Клауса Ріттера.
Колись на спаржу й полуниці "до Клауса" приїздило багато заробітчан
з Румунії та України. Але торік румунські заробітчани на спаржі
влаштували страйк, адже їм заплатили значно менше обіцяного.
У фермера не було грошей розрахуватися.
Спаржевий король Клаус Ріттер, як виявилося, збанкрутував.
У родині фермера Штайґера прогнозів на цей сезон уникають.
Ніхто цього не знає. Це залежить від багатьох чинників.
Відкриють ресторани чи не відкриють.
Можливо, трапиться щось ще гірше.
Як швидко просуватиметься кампанія зі щеплення.
Все це речі, на які ми не маємо жодного впливу.
Нам залишається лише реагувати.
Коронавірусу ані в родині, ані серед працівників тут поки не було.
Але німецький фермер боїться наврочити, адже з досвіду багатьох підприємств
знає, що захворювання можуть перекреслити усі виробничі плани.